[Music]
well of course I think you know just
first of all she's amazing mom
but the entertaining that she is she's
been entertaining for I know 14 years
now and doing it the best best way
possible so that's exciting the stuff
that she has coming up next is he's even
more fired so I'm so excited the energy
has been insane it's really been on
another level you know it just feels
good it's been a while and the fans have
just been giving so much love back and
with this song my mission is to inspire
the world to dance and to be their best
and make sure they get the best out of
life you know the love you're getting in
life your health and life your job in
life make sure you're just doing life
it's just living life at the best level
you know to me at the highest level so
that's my mission and it feels good the
worlds loving it what I love about you
too - you post dance videos all the time
y'all dance in your house yeah I groove
she dance
[Music]
when you woman in your life has she just
wrapped you are you done you know Sienna
is the cutest thing in the world and
she's got so much personality the thing
is she was dancing and she was dancing a
level up today right
and so she's grooving she's groove as
she screw and I'm like man she's got
better she's got better rhythm than me
she's one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]